sometimes I get asked the question who's
my role model you know and I guess the
answer to that is it probably depends it
at what age when I was really young and
probably did have role models that
really affected me I didn't know the
concept of a role model so I actually
think that the role models that if that
we have that really helped determine our
character I mean of course there are our
parents and our friends but made a
family but I don't think we really think
about that at a time when it has the
most effect later on in life you know as
you're an adult and you're you have your
teachers and I've had mine but I i guess
i don't i feel like i've had many not
just one and I've been very fortunate
for that reason and I think people who
are successful in life are our have the
wonderful accident of having having had
whether intentional or not sometimes you
find the person who you admire that's a
skill but this the ability to have that
skill to seek out a role model is
something that probably is acquired
through role models that we don't seek
out as a young scientist there there was
a great biochemist who was very very
influential to me and also i have to say
when you interview randy schekman I'm
sure you hear the same name his name was
Arthur Kornberg Arthur Kornberg was one
of the great biochemists of the 20th
century possibly the greatest biochemist
of the second half of the 20th century
he is he was my hero as as I was
learning biochemistry and I actually
left medical school without finishing my
medical doctor's degree in order to take
the opportunity to work in a laboratory
next to Professor kornberg my first job
as an independent scientist was as a
young professor at Stanford University
and Arthur
it was the chief of the department
really and actually was a great
inspiration to me the work that was
recognized in this Nobel Prize my
contribution to it began during that
period and I don't think that I would
have been as successful in doing what I
did if it were not for the kind of
scientific environment that he fostered
and the type of science that he
represented which we called enzymology
and he was without a doubt the master of
in zoology of his era and for me to have
the opportunity to take that discipline
to a new level you know under the
watchful eyes of the master was quite an
extraordinary experience he won the
Nobel Prize by the way many years ago
and I believe 1959